[Music]
we know that a relation is a set of
ordered pairs that satisfy a
relationship
this was the Cartesian product of sets P
and Q we've seen previously and this is
set R - this our relation here the
second number here is a multiple of the
first in each case now let's talk about
the terms image range domain and
codomain we know that the set R - has
three ordered pairs 2 comma 10 - comma
20 and 4 comma 20 here we can say that
10 is an image of - 20 is an image of 2
and 20 is an image of 4 we can say that
every Q in set our - is an image of its
P the set of P of all ordered pairs B
comma Q in set our - is called the
domain or we can say that the set of the
first elements of all the ordered pairs
in set R - is called the domains so we
can say that the domain contains the
elements - and for now it would be very
easy to guess what range means the set
of Q of all ordered pairs P comma Q in
set R - is called the range or we can
say that the second elements of all the
ordered pairs in the relation R is
called the range the range contains the
elements 10 and 20 so all the first
elements form the domain and all the
second elements form the range
what is the foe domain here the whole
set Q is called the codomain of relation
R so the codomain hell will contain the
elements 10 20 and 35 see see wasn't it
now I want you to look at the range and
the codomain and find a relation between
them what can we say we could say that
the range is a subset of the codomain
here is an arrow
Grahame to learn what is domain range
and codomain so this is the domain this
is the range and this is the co domain
for a relation our
[Music]
you